Who enjoyed my support?
I can hit you in the back with my hand.
For 30 minutes, 45 minutes, you get to understand why they paid him to be here today.
In the next 20, you'll understand why they didn't pay me.
But I've got a trick to make you more money.
Nothing but cards.
But today, we're going to talk about change.
Who wants to talk about change?
And we are here today with the intent of leaving with zero change in mind.
Seriously.
It's cold out there.
I'm from Miami.
It's real cold.
Y'all might be used to this, but that's what you got is cold out there.
You journey here today for change, right?
Same with us.
You can see we changed our name.
We used to be all things spray tanning, all things sunless, sunless ink.
You're welcome.
So we've changed to innovate beauty and wellness. We're taking the change and we're wanting to help you take that change with us. So I'm not going to be up here selling you and pitching you. What I'm going to be doing is like Mike said a little bit earlier, we talk collectively.
my sales team to thousands of people in 62 countries globally we have a message
for you not what to buy but how to use the modalities that you're looking at
because you can spend 50 60 thousand Canadian in the room next door but if
you don't know how to implement that equipment you're losing money you're
burning your money you're throwing it out the window because right now I've
I've talked to so many of you already
that have made the investment
but still don't have the people coming in the door, right?
It's happening.
It's already happening.
So if you're going to make the change,
I want to talk about real change.
Systemic change within your salon,
within your walls.
And it's going to start with an easy word.
Modality.
Say it with me.
The reason that's important is
if we're shifting to wellness,
We're shifting to more of a spa look and feel.
We have to get our vernacular down.
We have to teach our team who's next door the right things to say, like Mike was saying.
Not just appearance, but it's the entire display, the entire menu of things you have.
So, first of all, we no longer have equipment in room 1 through 10, 1 through 12, or however many rooms you have.
These are now modalities.
Fair enough?
Say it one more time.
Modalities.
Louder.
There we go.
All right.
So how well is your wellness working?
So I want to ask you, what different modalities have you brought in?
Come on.
Shout it out.
Well fit.
Red light.
What else?
Cocoon.
Lush.
Lush lamps.
Sauna.
Lamps, alright. What else? Massage, anyone do massage?
The weight bed.
The weight bed, the weight bed. Do you like that?
It's relaxing, right?
Here's one of the problems we've been making, alright?
We need to understand how large the market is.
And I'm going to use some analytics.
Like Michael said, analytics are going to really save us.
But 4% of U.S. households spray tan, and in Canada, it's 2% of U.S. households spray tan.
So if you're wondering why you have one person a day coming to spray tan,
it's because that's maybe how many you've attracted to come in.
But take a look at the piece of equipment that you may have.
As you're updating equipment, there's a whole plethora of new things that you can bring in,
new modalities. They're going to be dual serving of which we're going to talk about the new
well-fit machine. But more important, our new well-fit machine, it is a full body skin
care serum treatment in two minutes, right? Who's going to get out of their car, drive
all the way to your place in this cold, hop out, get naked for a two minute session in
a modality? Does that sound fun? That's cold. Even when you're in the room, it's a little
So what we need to do is when I'm coming in for the wave or for the red light, what am
I doing to pair my modalities for an experience?
One of the things I want to talk about is the market opportunities right here.
47% of the U.S. market right now, look at this skyrocket.
Up to $71.5 billion is the opportunity because skin care and skin tech is all of the rage.
and touchless. We need to use that word as well. Touchless. Because when you're talking
about touchless, like Mike said, you don't have a lot of employees in there. You have
people to clean, show up, turn on the lights. But a lot of this equipment is touchless.
That's a big range. Because if you go to a lot of spas and med spas, a lot of, we went
to just the other day to a, it's one of the massage places in the US. They do facials
as well. We decided to do massage and facial, but couldn't do the facial. Do you know why?
The person who did the facials wasn't there. And two people, that was about $240 that that
place lost because that person wasn't there and didn't show up. Some of the great things
about the modalities, two rooms down, they don't call in sick. They're going to be there.
They're going to look as good as you keep them. But to the market, again, 40% of this
skin care industry. Look at this number. 40% of beauty and personal care industry equates
to $218 billion. You may be in a small town. I've talked to some of you. I grew up in a
town of 600 people. My parents had flower shops with tanning in the back. Great combination,
right? That's like gas station sushi. It's weird. But it worked. It worked. Just because
because you're in a small town and they have 10 to 15,000 people, doesn't mean the people
in that town don't have a hierarchy, right? Small towns even have a bigger hierarchy.
What that means is what they're wearing, what they're doing, where they're going, where
they're spending their money. Sometimes you go to a town so small and everyone's hair
is the same color and the same white, right? Because there's one hair shot. What we need
need to do is look at the trends in our area and fuck the trends. Yeah, you heard me. What
we want to do is we want to create trends. With skin care and wellness, we're creating
trends. Is everyone coming to say that they want to go into the weight bed? No, not until
you brought it in. Is everyone asking for red light therapy? No, not until you bring
bring it in, and you teach and you show them the benefits of red light, you may not, I've
had many of you already today, I don't have a lot of people come in and ask me for spray
tape, because you don't have it. I'm not going to go to a sushi place and order a hamburger,
right? If you don't have something, people are not going to ask for it. The next thing,
real important, what consumers demand is important. What consumers demand, what do you demand
Do you go places? Are you demanding? Do you want the very best? Do we want the very best for our customers?
Now, Randy and I and Jennifer in the back, we travel to a lot of salons. Some good, some not so good.
A lot of them have things in common, but the biggest separation is something that Mike talked about.
It's not just appearance, but it's kind of the aura.
When you're stepping into a place, is your staff on the phone or are they engaging?
Are they TikToking or are they engaging the customers when they come in?
That's the biggest key.
The hotel this morning waited about 15, 20 minutes before somebody was at the front desk.
How long do we have to make that impression, to make that sale? Remember the seconds?
Fifteen.
Yeah, and I lost about ten minutes already with a stupid joke to start with.
We have only so much time to make that impression, and if you've been a UV tanning salon for
the last 10 to 15 years, when you bring in red light or a spray tan machine, that doesn't
change that you're not a UV tanning salon anymore.
Do you know what changes it?
You change it.
Your staff changes it.
Your social media changes that.
This is, I'm going to skip because I'm going to run out of time.
But 80%, 80% of the folks that are using our well-fit machine, 80% of them have never tanned in a tanning bed before.
Never tanned in a tanning bed.
When Mike was talking earlier about how many customers that you truly have, not how many that are in the computer, the system,
but how many really actually come to you on a daily, weekly, monthly, and yearly basis.
The one thing we're always trying to do is expand that.
It's very difficult to expand how many people spray tan
and how many people UV tan.
With the low-maintenance fruit right now,
it's sitting two rooms away called wellness.
Create the experience.
Some easy things to do, and you may want to write this down.
Things that we've seen on the road, super successful.
One of the biggest pain in the back end
when I come to a tanning salon it's getting undressed right and if I'm using
more than one room I'm getting undressed getting redressed getting undressed
getting redressed how can I change that how can I make it an experience you said
it over here roads roads how about a tote to put my clothes and all my junk in
so I put on a robe and I'm going to the next room listen me away to my next room
When we go to the spa, what I've always heard, even as a young wee little lad, every time
somebody went to the spa, it was a spa day, right?
Becoming wellness day.
After work, I want to relax.
What are some of the modalities that I can visit with you with simplicity, whiskey made
from room to room, making me feel like I want to be a part of your wellness center?
So analytics are important, but mindset and the change you're going to leave today, it's
like Mike said, you don't have to spend $200,000, $300,000 today to make real change.
Find him.
He's going to hide in some corners soon because there's going to be a line to get to him.
But talk to other salons that are here.
What are you doing?
What's been successful for you?
Because every pocket, every region gets a little bit different.
so i want to dive real quickly into the well-fit products because it is dynamically different from
anything that we've done but outside of cleveland ohio we manufacture all of our equipment we create
we have r d and labs that make all of our products solution from our spray tanning products
to our home application to our wellness home products that you can see on the table
which we're going to get into which are just absolutely amazing and can't be free to try them
But we are a skin care company, and we always have been.
But strategically, we've been so focused on the self-tan and the spray tanning part of it,
we look the gift horse in the mountain.
We have the labs.
We have the potential.
We have the products, just like you, to change.
And that's what we've done.
So with that, the WellFit was born.
Now, you can use WellFit with spray tan.
You can use it with UV tan.
You can use it with red light, with wave, with cocoon, with every other modality.
It is the first stop in your journey now when I come to you.
So it's going to accentuate every application and modality in the salon afterwards.
And I'm going to tell you why.
A few different products.
First one, hydrate.
Who's heard of hyaluronic acid?
Wow.
Come on.
I know more than five people who've heard of hyaluronic acid, right?
Typically, hyaluronic acid, we're doing T-zone, right?
It's expensive. It's in gels and creams. This is Skintec, the first of its kind, full body hydration. Hyaluronic acid and just upping it one, it's triuronic acid, those three layers deep in the skin.
skin. So it continues to work for over 24 hours. So yes, when you spray, you feel it immediately
because we're a spray tan company. It was very difficult for us to create something that you
didn't know something happened right away. You get a spray tan, you go in pale, you come out dark,
right? We wanted a change right away. Hydration for 24 hours. So when you wake up, your skin
still feels it. There's something called sodium PCA in the product that throughout the day
continues to gravitate the moisture from the environment onto your skin. So not only is
the hyaluronic acid amazing, there's other ingredients that make it very clean beauty
for face and full body. Full body, two minutes. All right? That's hydrate. Do you need anything
else? Of course you do. You need collagen. We're talking liquid Botox. You ready for
this. This right here restores collagen. What other modalities do you have that help with
collagen production? Red light, right? Now, there's a bunch of manufacturers that make
some amazing products that go with the red light. We're not going to slow down in the
selling of that, but this is a full body application of that product that most products are face
only this is full body two minutes so this is going to help accentuate the red light experience
next one we're going to talk about who's taking magnesium or potassium lately big trigger words
magnesium call me feels great helps oxygenate the body that is restored and the restorative
properties of this it even cools your body down when you get a spray with the product amazing
amazing. And then our newest one, balance. Now, first story on this one, when we were
testing it, our youngest is a gym lab. If you've got one, you understand. Creatine powder
like four times a day. They're doing pre-workout, after workout. It's their life. Well, they
get a little thing called acne. You ever heard of this? It's acne on the back. Well, he had
He had acne. He stole the bottle that I had at my desk in my office and sprayed it on and the next day it was gone. Balance helps with acne, psoriasis, eczema, you name it. If you have a skin condition, even if you don't, this helps with the natural biome of the skin and this is absolutely amazing.
So now you can see four products, a menu, you can come in and do two at a time if you
want.
You can do a hydrate and a lift or a lift and a balance, but you have a menu of items
that you can offer that are going to accentuate the entire experience.
So not only do these machines do all that, but if that 4% or 2% want to spray tan, they're
still going to perform a spray tan for you as well.
We have two different machines out there, we have the Versapro, that has a menu card
of allowing you to do four different products, and the new Mystic Unity has a menu card to
do eight.
So, the biggest difference in the two, that is it, on a very high level.
There's some pricing differences, of course, but if you're looking, depending on how many
folks you have in your area, if you're looking to up your game, because I know there's a
lot of older equipment within these cities.
And we need, it's about time we update that. But again, if you're only seeing one to two people spray tanning a day, it's very difficult dropping 50 grand to update and to increase from one to three, right? It doesn't pay for itself.
What you're doing, this is the only modality in the other room that is actually two things in one room.
It'll spray tan people, or it'll do the skin care serums, or both.
So, big change. Does it sound exciting?
How many words a minute do you think I'm saying? I feel like I'm talking fast, right?
Am I close to your dollar, like 700? No, 540.
Alright, proof and validation.
This is important. We did some testing and some studies with people in the usage of this product.
Do you see that very top number? Negative ratings. When does that ever happen that not one person that we tested did not like the product, the fragrance, the feel, the reaction?
98% wanted to continue. And this was after six treatments. This wasn't just one treatment.
You know how people, when you talk to them, did you like, yeah, it was great, and they
never come back.
This was after six treatments.
98% wanted to continue.
And remember from the analytics, 80% of the people that are using this modality never
came to your salon before.
So not only are you getting new folks, you're getting them like a boomerang.
These people are coming back over and over again.
All right.
Expand premium offerings.
science-backed credibility, differentiate with innovation, all of this is super important.
The funny thing is that so many of you that have come in just two rooms down already today,
we had a short window of about an hour.
There was two camps, really.
There was a camp, tell me more about this, and there was a camp that said, we don't have
anything like this.
What do you think your customers are going to do when they come in and you have this
menu and you say we have the latest in skin care technology in two minutes I can shower your entire
body with hyaluronic acid I can shower your entire body down with product called lift that'll help
build collagen do you know where they've seen this before nowhere no they're gonna see it with
you for the very first time and how many times is an industry have we had the ability to say we're
We're the only ones that offer this.
This is the only place you can get something like this.
And if you're in a big town, this is big city dreams right here.
This is what the big city is all about.
And if you're in a big city, well, this is just going to help you really pull yourself away from the competition.
Because there's many of you that have bought new machines, but you have not translated them into the skin care aspect.
And if you've already bought a Versapro, and I know some of you have recently, you can put the well fit in there. You do not have to buy a brand new booth to do that. So if you already have one of our pieces of equipment, we'll get you retrofitted and on your way.
But we don't want to just sell you new equipment.
Like I said earlier, we want to show you how to change how it is that you're doing business.
Not just calling yourself total tan and beauty and wellness and more.
But really changing the fabric of what everyone in your town thinks you are.
Because that's what's most important.
And you can only do that with visual change and that aura, the feel of what people feel when they come in.
Even to something like fragrance.
What is the fragrance that you have permeating at your wellness studio right now?
What music do you have playing?
Does it sound like a babbling brook?
Or is it the radio station has annoying commercials popping up?
Think about it.
When I go to a spa, there's usually a TV there.
You're seeing a little zenny, some candles.
What is the mood?
All right.
Proof of validation.
This is an RN that we had doing a lot of our testing.
This is one of Jen's really good customers.
She has a med spa.
She's up in the northeast, I think it is.
She's in Kentucky.
Georgetown.
That's not northeast at all.
But she brought it in.
And before even her med spa opened, we were the only modality there.
She built her business starting just off of the WellFit machine.
And this is somebody that has no UV tanning.
It's just a wellness center.
so we have doctors we have pretty much men's spa hospitality tanning salons
usually are the largest area where we've been placing these machines but men's
spa spa hospitality and wellness are very close second right now because you
have to understand as we migrate what do you think other businesses are doing
in right now even my dentist office is bringing in wellness equipment because they're seeing you
for a cleaning hopefully once a year right and oh you've got something bad where you need some work
done they want to make reoccurring revenue just the same just for an example so i'm just going to
skip real quick to our well-fit home this is going to be by far your new favorite at-home product
line. This is again a first. Is it the first serum and toner and scrub ever created? No,
but this is the first of its kind that is full body. Typically toners are going to be in a two
to four ounce bottle and it's just for your face in the morning or makeup removal. These products
are full body. You can see our toner mitt down here. Definitely my very favorite product of all
all time. It's in a plush mid. This right here is going to really help increase sales because this
is sold every time somebody goes into the WellFit machine, that plush mid has a saturation of the
toner that you put on that's going to heighten and accentuate the WellFit story. So this is a
pre-WellFit product. They can buy them and bring them home, but we have the full bottle for that.
This is just got done with work. I got to pick up the kids in about an hour. I want some me time.
all right. You've been sweaty, nasty, working on the keyboard all day, get a toner mitt,
hop in and get a well fit. But we also have the full bottle with rose water. This product
is so, so nice. We have it in packets as well to try. But we are running a special at the
show. If you are looking for a high-end skincare product to sell at your salon, you won't find
because they don't sell detaining salons. Dermalogica, a lot of these high-end skin care products.
Even those that have four or five hundred locations like down in the states and overseas, they cannot get high-end skin care products.
You can get this one. And the next one we have, glycolic acid scrub. This is like a weekly scrub, very intense.
and it feels absolutely amazing, and then the serum. Has anyone ever used a serum? Alright.
I had never used a serum before. I'm just going to be completely transparent with you.
I didn't even know this serum was for. I use a serum now. The tone is absolutely amazing,
but this is a trifecta of products that now you can sell. We have a lot of places that
we'll do intros because when it comes to skincare products, you want your customer buying in,
not just buying the products, but buying them that this needs to be part of the regimen.
So this becomes something that you're not just trying to sell one time. Like makeup
ladies, I know when you go to Sephora, they sell in what's called a quad of three. They
try to sell you four pitches of three products. They don't want you leaving Sephora without
out three products. Do you know why that is? Because they know when you use makeup, you're
going to come back to that brand and you're going to continue to use usually that shade,
that brand. It's the same thing here. Like Mike was talking about earlier, you've got
a very, very finite time where you can sell them, but you have to sell them properly.
And the great thing is, is we have an entire business development team that will help you
do that we have online classes we have you can do live with our with our development team and
education is the key because if your staff is scared of the products scared of the modalities
and the equipment they're not going to tell others how to use it what am i doing for time
all right so with that being said we always love coming here the energy is always great
we're going to be over there we're doing spraying faces if you want to try the hyaluronic acid it
It'll spray just your face.
It won't disturb your hair, your makeup, nothing.
It's a micro mist.
It penetrates.
It won't believe me.
I'm not going to mess anyone's makeup up today.
But you need to come and try.
You can come and ask as many questions as you can.
But we appreciate you all.
And then here's to a great 2026, everybody.
You're bright.
Thank you.
We're going to give away a full bottle of all-you-can-eat, all-you-can-eat, all-you-can-eat.
You ready?
Are the tickets ready?
Six.
Zero.
Seven.
Four, four, one, nine.
Six.
Zero.
Seven.
Oh!
Look at you, like a sign in the sky.
Congratulations.
Right here.
Just a picture for me.
Thank you.
It is a local organization here that actually works with entrepreneurs across the country
that's got some really unique and helpful funding opportunities for you guys.
So I wanted to bring her in so that we could learn from her and hopefully utilize her services
to help us grow. Everybody welcome Sarah.
I'm going the wrong way. Can you hear me? It's my microphone.
So I'm Sarah Wilson, Enterprise Brand. Enterprise Brand, we're a community of futures development organization.
And we're situated throughout Canada, and we have offices throughout Canada, but only in rural areas.
Now we, just to be clear, so myself, I'm general manager of the office here in the Brantford and Brantcombe area.
We have 61 offices throughout the province of Ontario and 267 offices across Canada.
If you're not located in a rural area and you need any kind of help with your business,
or if you're located in a rural area and you need any kind of help with your business,
just someone to talk to.
A nice, different, outside partner.
So someone that's separated from your business with lots of business experience.
Our office is a place. So you're looking for a community future.
What will happen is if you're not in the area, they will direct you to someone in your area.
So if you're located in Vancouver, BC, you won't have a community future, but there will be one just outside of Vancouver,
and they will be able to tell you the offices in Vancouver that can help you.
We're a board of directors, so we're not for profit, we're funded by the government,
and we're governed by a board of directors that is always from our local area.
So each office is run to meet the needs of our communities.
So in the office we run in Brantford is different and provides different services than the office that we run in Oxford.
We provide financing for start-ups, for maintenance, for expansion to help you reach your dream.
We've heard our speakers, the last couple of speakers talk about your dream.
What is your dream? Where do you want to take your business? Do you have a plan for that?
We will help you get there. So we want to help you through financing, through consulting,
through helping you develop a plan to get to your dream or to start taking the steps towards the dream
that you have for your business. So what do you need to do? You need to be prepared.
You see businesses that have run successfully for years, that are ready for expansion, but they're not prepared.
Maybe they've run successfully, maybe they didn't keep their Canada regulations in place.
Maybe they didn't put away some money in good records.
So you need to view. So right now you need to have established, start establishing good credit process as well as your business process that we're talking about. Because as a business owner, you're going to look at your personal situation as well as your business situation inside of how we help you and whether we can lend money.
Keep good financial records.
There are so many business owners out there.
They have a bookkeeper who does their records.
They need to have their agency paid on time.
They need to have their payroll done.
They have someone else doing that.
They're not on top of it.
Or they know a little bit about it, but they're not sure what's going on day to day.
You're the owner.
It's up to you to know what those numbers are and what's happening in your business.
So you may have a book that comes into your office.
You may have one that's outside.
I know you use tools when you take on your payments.
And that tool, you know, keeps track of your sales and your product lines,
if your sales are on those product lines.
If you don't have those tools, implement tools.
They give you the information that you need to know what's happening in your business.
What products are selling well?
Understand what's selling well.
What's making money?
We've heard some talk about the standard tanning booth that maybe two clients a month are using it.
Does it make sense to continue that?
Do you want to invest money into that, that we'll maybe have, or you don't want?
Make sure you are well-optimized.
If you have a new business idea, an expansion you want to do, you're just struggling,
and you need some help figuring out where you're making money, where you're not making money,
what's new up there, what can I do with my business?
But you need to have information when you come to us, you need to be able to show us that, you know, these are the product lines I sell, this is what I paid for it, and then we can do some analysis, and we can say, okay, maybe it's time to do the product line.
I'll talk to you later on as I go through an example of the finance we did.
A bunch of people would come in and do business for them and realize that they were running services that were not making them any money.
They were actually costing them.
And so they were able to look at their business and decide, you know, what, you know, and decide who cut those product lines.
and take advantage of the resources to use in the community.
So in Ontario, we are in the community futures offices.
Every city has a business enterprise and resource centre as well.
Our services are all free.
So you don't get paid when you walk in the door.
And we're going to talk...
It's a listening ear to hear what's happening with your business.
And we're available there to share our expertise we've seen and want.
I've been working with businesses for just around 40 years and I have seen a lot of things.
So I've been able to advise businesses so they can continue that are on the edge, not
the middle.
The fact that you're here today, because that means that you want to invest in this
and you want to move into this.
So be prepared.
Have your credit ready.
Know what it is.
If you need some help determining what your credit is, what your score is, that type of thing, or how you approve it, our office can provide that, provide you with that information.
Pay your bills and especially those government credits. That's a barrier to being able to finance your business.
Research your business idea, what you want to do to go to the next level, and take advantage of those resources.
So what we do, so what we require, when we're looking at a company for financing, there are several documents and this is not just for us. So our business is to get you financed or get you to the next step. We aren't necessarily going to do the financing.
We do have financing available. We finance businesses that traditionally can't fit within the boxes of the bank's finance. We have more flexible lending. So if you're having a slow time or something happens in your business where you lose a key employee and you're having a hard time marketing,
then we can extend so we were set up to take care of businesses that aren't
traditionally financed by the chairman or for some reason or another
security maybe you haven't been in business long you may have had a few
startup years or a few years where you have negative net income. Those are the businesses that we will look at financing, we will look at your finances.
So, whether you're looking for financing from our organization or from a government organization, you will need to provide them with information.
That information, you should prepare that ahead. You want to make your best marketing effort when you go to that financer.
You don't want to go to them and have them ask you for the documents.
You want to bring your package to them.
Your package already granted.
So planning is a key to put into practice in order to receive funding.
So for an existing business, ongoing business, so nothing for a financial statement for two years.
And that's for an existing business.
And all of you are an existing business.
If you are going to be purchasing an additional business, we would be looking for your financial
statements and the other financial statements that a seller should be able to provide those
to you if you've signed an intent to purchase the business.
Personal financial statements.
So a personal financial statement is your assets and your liabilities, your personal
assets.
So, in your assets you're going to list your home if you own one, your vehicle, any investments,
mutual funds, any other assets if you own a boat, if you own a cottage, if you own a
camper.
You're going to list all of the assets that you own and then your landlord is going to
list all of the debt that you owe.
They may not have worked during the war.
You may own some money on your car.
You may own some money on your credit cards.
So we want to know where your personal financial situation sits.
You will have, if you own a business, you will have HST permits
that you have made, potentially corporate tax,
if you're in a corporate HST business,
and payroll in Texas that you've had to pay your payroll remittance for.
And with each of those, you receive a notice of assessment from the government.
You need to have those available to us.
They can be downloaded to use here as soon as you are able.
If you do not, or do not have the credentials to sign up for your Canada Revenue Agency account online,
I suggest that you put that in place so that you can see what's happening with your business.
Boy, I have true self-adventure thinking on the invoice so I really want to do it.
A business plan.
Without a plan, how are you going to proceed?
I have no idea why you do this shit.
A business plan is a written document that tells me who you are as the owner,
what your business does, and how you intend to run your business.
So that's a key piece. That's your marketing features for the bank.
It tells us what you plan to do.
Cash flow projections are an estimate of how you're going to, what cash is coming into your business,
which cash is going out of your business, how your cash flow is going to look with the new expansion you're doing or the new financing.
So that would be a 12-month spreadsheet, a monthly projection of the cash flow and the cash flow.
I'm going to give you a couple of financing examples for businesses that we financed.
People do these very quickly.
So we financed a tanning salon purchase.
This was a number of years ago.
She was buying a profitable new business, an ongoing operation, creating new equipment.
She had worked in the business, so she was an employee.
She had excellent credit, so that means she had paid her bills on time and established
a good company.
And it was a viable business.
She worked with the employer to develop a business plan and brought it back.
The lease on the location was transferred.
So the tanning salon purchased, we advanced $100,000, sorry, the purchase for the $100,000, we advanced $85,000 to the person who was selling, and then she included a $15,000 in personal investment.
investment. We set up a seven-year repayment term. Now our interest rates are prime plus 2%.
So the security on the other hand...
Can you say that again? Prime plus what?
2%. So right now prime is 4.45, so that would be 6.45. We do add a risk rating to that, so 8.5%.
and when she did this, the program was at 5%.
And then monthly payments of $13.50
and the loan is fully open to pay off.
And that's something when you're doing financing
is the rate might be a little bit higher,
but if you leave it open to pay off when you want,
then life is more flexible.
Now, the second example, it was a spa expansion in that congregation.
So this individual, or this, there were two individuals, and they own a spa.
They don't have tendons, but they have a myriad of some of the other spa treatments that have been helpful today.
So they were doing, they were taking over the unit next to them.
So they were doing their expansion, they were doing their leasehold improvements, so updating that area.
Consolidation of existing debt. This included some credit card debt, as well as they had the banks offer a small business financing loan for equipment.
And they had entered into one, it's a very set payment, and they cover 80% income up to 20%.
So they were unable to make all their debt payments along with the new financing and feel comfortable with their cash flow. So we consolidated that debt. So that is one thing that we do need to look at.
So if you have a piece of equipment that you're paying on, and you want to borrow or you need to do extra marketing, or you want to do both, buy a new piece of equipment and marketing, we can finance it all together. We can give you a lower rate stretch than time-out. So that is one of the advantages of our office.
so this ongoing profitable operation they had had difficulties during the pandemic
and they were a little behind on their agency we were able to pay out their agency debt to
the government because for us we're government funded so we do not if you have debt with canada
revenue agency we either have to pay it out as part of the room or we can't do the financing
you know so that's why it's important to me and that is good credit and well-developed
so with this one it was a hundred eighty five thousand dollar loan you required no down payment
because they were an existing business and had successful operations um the uh the hundred
thousand was for the expansion so that was quickly sold improvement adding additional equipment
and a little bit of working capital for the staff to get the new lines going.
10 year repayment, 7.5% interest for this one, and monthly payments of $2,340 and again over the payout.
So that gives you an idea of what you can finance and how you might finance it.
it. Look for your community office in your area. If they're not in your area, they will
guide you to someone in your area who can provide the services. We refer a lot of clients
to banks because they're bankable as well. And everything is possible. Just come to us
with a plan of how you think you might make it happen and we can help you make the next
So we have lunch is served in the hallway. Sarah will be hanging out for lunch. If you guys have any questions, this is a really cool opportunity to look at different options for financing. When we introduce new equipment into salons, I would say 90% of the time we're leasing it. Leasing is expensive. So I'm trying to offer you guys some insight in different ways to fund your growth and your bottom line.
So whether or not you're in southwestern Ontario or not, grab Sarah, she can direct you in the right direction,
and hopefully there's opportunities for you guys to make more money and spend less doing it, okay?
If you guys need the slides, reach out to me and I've got a copy of them, and we can make sure that you guys have that contact information.
But if we could give Sarah a round of applause.
Please serve. You guys are welcome to go out and grab a plate and then come back in here.
Thank you so much.